[Music]
i gotta talk about something gotta get
something off of my chest so i'm a
millennial and so i keep up with the
the burgeoning social media trends that
are out there and one of those is tick
tock i do it for you guys so that i know
what's going on out there so i can fill
you all in
and there's a lot of
how do i say this
financial gurus out there
um who can't grow facial hair yet and
they are giving some terrible financial
advice
that truly makes my blood boil and it's
one of the reasons why i want to get in
there i don't want to i don't want to
become a tick-tock star i just have to
get in the middle of the mess and walk
everyone off the ledge because they're
listening to 60 second videos and then
making huge financial decisions because
of it
so here's what we're going to do we're
going to play a video that producer
james found that made my blood boil he
really knows how to push my buttons
we're going to react to it and then
we're gonna teach you guys a better way
so let's roll that beautiful bean
footage
when i'm 30 i want to be debt-free and
owe no credit cards you know you might
regret that what how well how are you
planning on getting a house or a car
yeah i'm just gonna use all cash by
chance that dave ramsey teach you this
yes why that advice is for people who
are already in debt or don't know how to
manage their money the truth is credit
cards can help build your credit which
is very important and if you pay them
off in full you'll never owe any
interest and with housing prices so high
good credits might be the only way most
people are going to be able to get a
house now that i think about it saving
up four hundred thousand dollars in cash
doesn't sound very reasonable that
advice might work for some but personal
finance should never be a
one-size-fits-all follow to learn the
truth
okay wow that moved so fast i thought i
was having a stroke for a second all
right i don't want to have to watch that
again so let me recap it for you because
he was moving pretty fast
he was saying
that it is unwise to save up 400 000
cash
to get a house and that our advice is
terrible and on top of that that you
need to be building your credit score
you need to be open to that credit card
going into debt staying in debt paying
it off all perfectly so that you can
build that beautiful fico score
i'm here to tell you that uh he
ended it with
learn the truth follow to learn the
truth
and the truth is that that is a lie
and here's why i know that's a lie
because i have purchased a house without
a credit score and i didn't save up four
hundred thousand dollars cash to do it
and what he's doing is he's playing into
the fomo that a lot of young people feel
out there
where they go man the dave ramsey guy he
wants us to save up and pay cash for a
house that's insane that'll take me 38
years
why wouldn't i just put zero down and
get in on this and then i'll get more
real estate and i can leverage more debt
but also i have a car payment i have
student loans
i've got medical bills
and then life crushes you and you go
well
that advice sounded good in theory but
in reality i want to have financial
peace
and so here's let me tell you our actual
advice when it comes to housing just to
make things clear
yes we don't want you to have any debt
at all the only type of debt that we
won't yell at you for is a 15-year
fixed-rate mortgage where you can put 10
to 20 percent down and the payment ends
up being no more than a quarter of your
take-home pay
that's exactly what i did me and my wife
in fact we put more than 20 down because
we didn't want to be in debt any longer
than we had to and so we sacrificed we
did side jobs we hustled for a long
period of time in order to put that much
down and then we ended up paying off the
house in 26 months and we did our debt
free scream just a few months back and
it was incredible on top of that when we
got the mortgage we did not have a
credit score because we had paid off our
debt long ago
and that leaves your credit score
indeterminable
and so you've all heard that you want to
have you know 750 800 850 perfect credit
score in order to go into debt that's
all it is
it's an i love debt scores playing kissy
face with the bank
and too many young people are learning
this and guess who they're learning it
from
their parents
when they turn 18 the parents go you got
to open a credit card and they go why
well you got to have the credit score
well why so you can get a car loan so
you can get a massive mortgage with
nothing down
here's what a credit score is made up of
35 percent debt history 30 percent
current debt level 15
how long you've been in debt 10
any new debt 10
type of debt are you hearing a theme
debt
that's right so
you don't need a credit score to buy a
car because we're gonna pay cash for
cars
i've done it multiple times it's amazing
they'll actually take your money
you don't need to use credit cards to
build your score because we're paying
cash for things with our debit card and
we're budgeting
you don't need it to rent a car and i
can tell you that because i've done it
multiple times sometimes they'll just
add a buffer maybe let's say twenty
percent of your total will be added as a
deposit on your checking account
temporarily
you don't need it to rent a house or an
apartment
and i've called all over the country we
did this on the fine print on our credit
score episode and almost every single
one said oh i mean that's fine if you
don't have a score now a low score will
hurt you but no score that's fine you
just might need to pay an extra you know
first month last month an extra deposit
that's it
and then finally the big one you don't
need it to buy a house
and our friends at churchill mortgage do
this every day it's called manual
underwriting or a no score loan and they
do it like they did back in the old days
where they just look at your actual
financial picture they look at pay stubs
your w-2s do you pay your utility bills
that kind of thing
and they go okay well based on your
situation we're happy to give you a loan
because we know you're gonna pay it back
and so that's what we did
and most people are shocked by this we
did i did a media hit for a new station
over in chicago and they were just
flabbergasted that someone could even
buy a house without a credit score and
so we need to start dispelling these
myths and parents you got to stop
telling your kids this and tick talkers
you got to stop spreading this
misinformation because that video has
millions of views
and the comments are all very thankful
and they're all going yeah that dave
ramsey guy man what a scam artist
because he tells you to get out of debt
and stay out of debt because he wants
you to build wealth and have financial
peace
so
tick-tock at your own risk i'm not
telling you to go there i'm just telling
you
if you want some entertainment or you
want to get angry it's a fun place to be